[Musica]
loro sono i miei figli giulia emma e
cesare una rossa 1 bionda e una mora
sono profondamente diversi ma lo sono
non solo perché non si assomigliano
fisicamente ma anche perché sono o
perché ma abbia la sindrome di down
ma perché sono tre esseri umani unici e
irripetibili
una delle mie più grandi frustazioni di
madre è stata quella di non essere in
grado di relazionarmi con loro nello
stesso modo di crescere nello stesso
modo educarli nello stesso modo
non so poi secondo quale schema mentale
avrei dovuto farlo ma credevo che
altrimenti sarei stata impari invece ho
imparato che per essere equi e
necessario essere in pari a che cercare
di essere uniformi nell'educazione è
un'assurdità e soprattutto non è
rispettoso dell'identità di ciascuno
[Applauso]
in questa multiformità c'è il rischio di
perdersi ma c'è anche l'occasione di
rinnovarsi continuamente credo che sia
stata la mia secondogenita a stravolgere
la mia idea di educazione e la mia
visione sugli esseri umani
la sua disabilità ha messo in
discussione ogni mia certezza e mi ha
offerto una prospettiva nuova
sull'essere umano ma iniziamo dall
inizio quando è nata emma non sapevo che
avesse la sindrome di down
non lo sapevo perché avevo scelto di non
saperlo
sapevo solo che era femmine che era sana
perfetta dichiara la dottoressa dopo
l'ultima ecografia non aveva preso un
abbaglio e ma stava bene
emma era una bambina come tutti gli
altri ma con un cromosoma in più la
prima notte fu quella della paura la
paura dell'ignoto
non sapevo cosa aspettarsi alla mia
bambina e alla nostra famiglia
dovetti archiviare l'immagine che mi
hanno fatta di lei e passa in rassegna
tutto quello che sapevo o forse dovrei
dire non sapevo sulla sindrome di down
cerca i ricordi se avevano pensavo di
non aver mai incontrato persone con la
sindrome da in realtà a scavando nei
ricordi mi resi conto che c'erano stati
degli incontri mero stata indifferente
all'argomento è come se le cose non
esistessero finché non capitano a te
quella notte mi venne a trovare una
dottoressa mi raccontò che aveva un
fratello con la sindrome di down
entra nella mia stanza aveva delle
fotografie in mano era notte fonda mi
parlò di lui quel che la notte
io ero angosciata terrorizzata
completamente sotto shock ma
quell'incontro fu una zattera in un mare
in tempesta
il giorno dopo arrivano un sacco di
visite e telefonate una collega mi
scrisse che sfiga così via sms
insomma torto non ne aveva visto che
capita uno su 800 ma non mi sono mai
sentita sfigata nemmeno benedetta in
verità non sono una grande fan del dono
della sindrome non penso che sia un dono
non penso di essere un eletta una mamma
speciale una mamma scelta per un bambino
speciale
non credo che mia figlia sia un angelo
venuto insegnarmi qualcosa sulla vita ma
detto questo non mi sono nemmeno mai
sentita sfigata per fortuna poi ci sono
stati anche gli amici
tra questi berta la ricordo come la
miglior telefonata di quei giorni
ascolto infatti non fece commenti e mi
chiese soltanto cosa posso fare per te
le dissi portami dei libri saggio
romanzo una storia lei era mio guru
sull'argomento suo padre era un libraio
eccezionale e mi conosceva bene sapevo
che avrebbe scelto il libro giusto per
me mi portò clara va al mare
la storia di una ragazza con sindrome di
down che interrompe la sua routine si
ribella prende un treno e va al mare da
sola così e insaputa di tutti lo lessi
nella notte e mi si aprì un mondo di
possibilità
una storia può salvare un libro può
salvare
cominciò così la mia risalita dal buco
nero in cui ero caduta davanti alla
parola sindrome di down
grazie alla condivisione di una storia
di una dottoressa e un libro credo che
le storie costruiscono la nostra cultura
e dopo una città di m
mi sono totalmente immersa nelle storie
ho letto tutto quello che c'era
sull'argomento mi sono iscritto a un
forum online ho incontrato genitori e
famiglie e soprattutto o mi sono
avvicinata persone ad adulti con
sindrome di down li ho conosciuti
li ho ascoltati e in quella conoscenza
mi sono aperte
prospettive nuove e speranze concrete in
questi 14 anni ho imparato che il nemico
numero uno della nostra comunità non è
altro che l'ignoranza proprio intesa
come non conoscenza non è la cattiveria
o la discriminazione non esiste una
discriminazione senza un preconcetto
culturale penso agli stessi preconcetti
che avevo io quando è nata emma avevo la
testa piena di tutto quello che pensavo
mia figlia non potesse fare o non
potesse essere credevo che fosse l'amore
l'antidoto a questa paura a questo
pregiudizio
invece ho scoperto che è una piccola
rivoluzione che possiamo fare tutti
l'ho imparato dai bambini come avviene
questo questa magia del prendere la
confidenza con la diversità
l'ho imparato dai compagni di scuola
alle elementari di mia figlia
i bambini davanti la diversità
all'inizio sono in imbarazzo ma lo
dichiarano il loro disagio
cosa che in genere non fanno gli adulti
mi hanno spesso guardato con gli occhi
pieni di domande e mi hanno chiesto ma
che cosa emma perché è ma parla così
perché è maglia o chiamando la sapete
come risponde oggi emma che a 14 anni
sono nata così e chiude l'argomento
perché la sindone non ne vuole parlare
ma anche perché la risposta giusta è
l'unica risposta possibile
non c'è altro da aggiungere emma è nata
così dovremmo tutti avere il coraggio e
la determinazione di essere noi stessi
fino in fondo
i bambini davanti alla diversità
chiedono e spesso le risposte bastano
io ho usato quasi sempre la stessa
metafora la metafora che usavo con emma
e i miei figli quando sono arrivate le
prime domande è ma uno zainetto sulle
spalle e spesso è molto pesante e per
questo fa più fatica a far le cose e ci
mette più tempo a fare le cose ma ci ha
messo più tempo a fare tutto a camminare
a parlare a leggere a scrivere e le
parole mi hanno sempre fatto i dispetti
e gliene fanno tuttora i compagni di
emma
dopo un po si abituano e ma non è più
quella strana mm con le sue
caratteristiche e le sue peculiarità
i suoi compagni fanno quello che vorrei
facessero tutti guardano emma e non ha
la sindrome
per noi adulti è più difficile
noi abbiamo la testa piena di
sovrastrutture di esperienze
noi affrontiamo la diversità con le
informazioni che abbiamo già una hit
avevamo immaginario già formato in
genere non ci proviamo neanche a
conoscerlo il diverso gestirà lo
gestiamo con le informazioni che abbiamo
già in proposito ma allora come si fa a
entrare in contatto con la diversità
come si fa a includere senza rimanere
intrappolati nelle nostre conoscenze e
le nostre esperienze
noi dobbiamo tenere aperto il nostro
immaginario
dobbiamo inserire nuove immagini nuove
storie e nuovi esempi di riferimento
come
per esempio nel caso della disabilità
dandogli visibilità penso alla
televisione quella buona
penso alla cinema al teatro alla
letteratura alla pubblicità e penso
anche la vita quotidiana
dobbiamo far vedere storie di persone
con disabilità incluse a scuola al
lavoro nella vita sociale e far vedere
quanto diverse sono fra di loro
dobbiamo prendere a picconate il muro
del pregiudizio storia dopo storia negli
ultimi 40 nell'immaginario cambiato
tantissimo fa cultura a vedere un
bambino con sindrome di down
protagonista della campagna
pubblicitaria di zara una giovane donna
ragazza copertina della rivista della
compagnia aerea brasiliana o una giovane
donna un'attrice in un film
straordinario o in prima serata in tv
intervistata un ballerino straordinario
in un talent in televisione dove la
sindrome un di cui è quello che si vede
è solo suo straordinario talento
queste storie vanno raccontate per
cambiare il nostro immaginario nella
vita quotidiana
non c'è la forza la potenza i numeri dei
media della televisione ma c'è la
potenza della vita vera
vedere un ragazzo con sindrome di down
che serve un caffè al bar o che lavora
in un ristorante o un supermercato
che effetto vi fa mi stupisce vidi te o
guarda può anche lavorare
ecco quella domanda quello stupore sono
l'inizio della rivoluzione
significa che sta cambiando qualcosa
nella nostra mentalità
nicolò 29 anni a due lavori lavora in un
ristorante e albergo etico albergo etico
forma altri ragazzi con disabilità
intellettiva per entrare nel mondo del
lavoro ha corso tre volte la maratona di
new york i suoi 42 chilometri e 195
metri sono gli stessi che ha percorso
l'etiope che ha vinto l'ultima edizione
della maratona di new york
ognuno ha il suo passo ma la stessa
strada percorsa spartaco elena 43 45
anni stanno insieme da 15 anni lavorano
entrambi lui un operaio lei una
collaboratrice scolastica vivono insieme
a un'altra coppia a pordenone e hanno
appena deciso di sposarsi sparto che
orfano ed è stato per me la risposta
alla grande e drammatica domanda del
dopo di noi
marta sudano
marta 25 anni lavora e piena stata
assunta a tempo indeterminato in
un'azienda a marzo ha parlato le nazioni
unite e il suo speech hanno fatto
letteralmente venir giù il palazzo di
vetro tutti gli speakers dopo di lei
l'hanno citata lei mi ha parlato della
self fulfilling prophecy la profezia che
si autoavvera
in sostanza se tu pensi che l'altro non
capisca ti comporti di conseguenza non
gli spieghi che di conseguenza fi
avverare la profezia vi ho raccontato
tre storie di adulti
io ho scelto degli adulti
intenzionalmente perché la rete è i
media sono pieni di storie di bambini
belli e felici
l'immagine dei bambini con disabilità e
gesto ga nata io voglio la stessa
attenzione sugli adulti perché la
sindrome non ce l'hanno solo i bambini i
bambini crescono e la maggior parte
della loro vita la passano da adulti
quando sono adulti
la parola chiave è opportunità quello
che vogliono
quello che chiedono dammi una
possibilità credi in me spiegami le cose
in modo semplice quello che vogliono è
un amore un lavoro un amico una vita
indipendente non è quello che vogliamo
tutti
vi ho raccontato queste storie non
perché siano storie eccellenti ci sono
tantissime storie di persone con
sindrome di down interessanti e che
andrebbero raccontate ci sono anche
story faticose che non vanno dimenticate
anche quelle val la pena raccontare
non voglio nemmeno ispirarvi la rete è
piena di immagini di persone con
disabilità che sono lì ad acchiappare
like o a ispirare e motivare in genere
chi ha una disabilità non ce l'ha
ecco non voglio fare questo quando parlo
di dare visibilità alle persone con
sindrome di down e disabilità
intellettiva e condividere storie non
parlo di questo raccontare storie serve
a cambiare il nostro immaginario serve a
farci vedere quanto variegata
interessante sia natura umana serve a
dire che essere differenti è normale e
riconoscere che in fondo abbiamo tutti
gli stessi bisogni umani quando le
incontri le persone con sindrome di down
cono e le conosci scopri che non si
somigliano non esiste un loro una
categoria esiste l'individuo l'essere
umano
ecco che siamo tornati là dove abbiamo
incominciato loro non sono i miei figli
sono giulia emma e cesare la diversità
non è qualcosa di cui dobbiamo avere
paura qualcosa a fuggire
[Applauso]
la diversità non è qualcosa di cui
dobbiamo avere paura qualcosa da cui
dobbiamo fuggire non non c'è una lotta
da fare per essere tutti uguali
un canone di normalità a cui dobbiamo
aderire
eccolo qui conta è che la natura umana è
differente e variegata e quello che noi
dobbiamo fare è incontrarla e lasciarci
cambiare come avviene in tutte le
relazioni link
l'inclusione a cui aspiriamo a qui
l'unica chiave l'unica possibilità di
uscita
quello che dobbiamo capire è che la
diversità è una sfaccettatura della
natura umana
quello che abbiamo tutti noi in comune è
la diversità
se riusciamo a liberarci del di quello
sguardo di imbarazzo anche di pietà e
riusciamo a guardare l'altro liberi da
etichette pian piano quell'altro
diventerà sempre meno estraneo
e allora incontreremo l'essere umano e
non la sua fragilità
il suo paese d'origine la sua religione
o il suo orientamento sessuale
la rivoluzione e culturale e pretende un
cambio di prospettiva prendere
confidenza con la diversità e accettare
l'altro per quello che è
è quello che renderà possibile la
convivenza con gli altri esseri umani e
più umano il nostro futuro
grazie
[Applauso]